How do you, how do you deal
with people like the haters?
Because there's so many people.
I call them thumb thugs,
but how do you deal there?
There's hate in the dark.
I don't know what they're doing.
You don't read all those comments there?
I don't read shit anymore, man. A
very, very rarely go into mentioned.
If I do, it's usually a mistake. I
just, I just do my best, do my best.
I post and I go, I post and ghost. You
don't even look at people's feeds, do?
No. I look at some people's
feeds on Instagram when I'm
bored. You know, I'm, I'll,
I'll read some things. You know, I
want to look at some cool pictures.
I watched some inspirational shit.
I like going to the rocks,
seen him lifting weights. May
pumped up. I want to go to the gym.
Let me do the rock is,
let me tell you it Fletcher.
I interviewed the rock
the first time I met him.
I was like 11 years ago during the game
plan and we just hit it off right game
playing the game plan.
That's where he played a quarterback
because he was a lot thinner.
It's his first breakout movie that he
did Scorpion and then the game plan.
And after that interview, uh, he
took some time and just talk to me.
He wasn't the rock then. I mean
he was, and then over the years,
every time I interviewed him,
he would pull me aside and go,
are you going to my acting coach? Are
you doing this? Are you doing that?
Is there anything I can help you
with? And I'm like, what? Like,
and then he got bigger and bigger and
the last time I saw him, same thing, Yo,
are you doing,
are you going to acting coach?
Are you working on your goals or your
improved like literally his Instagram but
in real life and um, and it's,
and he'll never know this,
but it's the thing that's
for me just average Schmo,
Michael Yo d to take the time out.
Every time I interview him to
ask me if I'm achieving my goals,
if I'm moving forward in life,
giving me positive things,
positive thoughts to take that time
like five minutes after every interview.
And this dude is booked nonstop,
but to actually take time and it's just
so inspirational in to see him be the
biggest movie star in the world.
And he knows everybody's name.
He's very respected. I don't know
if he has an earpiece, but like,
it's like he's like the president when
he walks, he knows everybody's name.
He could be president. He,
oh hundred percent hundred
percent could be predators.
He cannot run through forum.
I went to, because he,
he's just a hard also comes
from humble beginnings. Yes.
You mean he's in Hawaii right now
and he's filming on his Instagram.
He's talking about all the neighborhoods
that he goes back to to check to see
where he was. Where's from when he was
poor and starving. Yeah. You know, I mean,
he really is from humble beginnings.
I mean he, he had only like, you know,
it's the story of like $5 left in as
account and then he got discovered and
wrestling and I knew him in
Miami when he was doing WWE.
I interviewed him a couple
of times over there and,
and he played for the University of Miami.
My favorite college football team.
So it's a thing where, you
know, the history of 11 years,
but for him that big to take
time to motivate me separately.
And you know, I know if he
sees me out, he knows my name,
but it's not like I'm texting,
I'm not like Kevin Hart with them and
just to be a random dude that he takes
time out every time he sees me to make
sure I'm hitting my goals and moving
forward with my career and not
back and then offering, hey,
if you ever need anything, get
in touch with me. You know,
I would never take them up on that.
But it's a thing where I'm nobody,
he's the rock. And to be
that inspiration, I mean it,
it just does so much man.
Like it.
Little things that big celebrities do
or somebody that really inspires you.
Like they don't know how much that means.
Like just that little time he spins it,
it'd so much. I think he does
know, I think he's a genuine
leader. He is, you know,
100% that's why so many people like him
because what he says is it's authentic.
It's really who he is.
There is nothing fake about that man.
You don't have to be fake.
You just have to be successful.
And if you want to work as hard as
that guy, you can be successful. I,
I asked one day,
I was like,
do you just take a bunch of pictures at
the gym like in just posts throughout
the day because you're always at that
big from taking pictures for no man.
That guy's picking heavy shit up. That's
too big. But you know what? I left.
That's just too big Joe stuff. Too Big
for him. No, he's an action star Dude.
And he's the first action
start at looks like an egg.
Like I would want him to save my life in
real life. Wow. What does he like six,
seven or some shit like that.
And like he's, he's this giant,
he's a little bit taller than me.
I'm seeing these giant,
he's built like a fucking like legitimate
superhero. Like, will Smith was my guy,
but I left will Smith for the rock.
And you left him? No, no, no. I stayed.
He's still, well, no, no, no. But
like you gotta do what you gotta do.
Burning, building a burning
building. Who's going to save you?
Who's going to save you?
Will Smith let me save you two
aliens coming at you.
Uh, Independence Day.
Did you not see will Smith Save the
world? I dug my look. I love will Smith.
An earthquake. An earthquake. Well,
if you want someone to hold one hand on
the top of a building and then hold your
wrist with another and know that he's
got you according to the movie poster,
that's the rock. See, I never saw will
Smith holding the top of the building.
[inaudible] shoot a gun by the hand.
Will Smith can shoot a gun? Those,
those zombies he did. I am legend.
Oh Man. What a great fucking movie.
Oh my goodness. Great. Fuck moving. God.